Alexander Payne like he does these like
really personal like human stories and
like part of what was so surprising to
me beyond this being exciting a
different concept that I was expecting
was to see it coming from him yeah see
like an interesting like kooky sci-fi
plot but from a guy who I know does a
lot of really human character but it's
not a life and family and heart and his
stories there so I heard downsizing I
was under pinochle like oh it's gonna be
one of those heartfelt stories about a
guy getting fired what's going on
reject nation I am Greg Alba I'm John
Humphrey don't say your name's Jay
Washington this is Jay Washington mr.
Jay Washington on Twitter and Instagram
trusty sidekick podcast so the trusty
sidekick podcast is all about
it's like ass of myself and Bobby hill
we get you covered and caught up on
everything in the Marvel and DC TV shows
a cinematic universe so everything
live-action we talk about and we just
talk about in like two regular dudes who
are grown men who are big dudes who are
fans and you show so is it sounding like
a regular recap like Lulu's have a known
Supergirl we do and you know we get real
with and people actually appreciate that
that we keep it honest respect them so
yeah we do that too Harry yeah two E's
what I do is I scroll through comments
and then I just say whatever they're
saying the easiest way to get likes on a
video already read all the comments for
this trailer about to watch downsizing
down son keep it a real okay bearskin
Peterson shout out of the day will go to
you after the reaction
we're proud from there the only
practical remedy to humanity's greatest
problem
are you ready doctor yes I'm ready Oh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
different you mean all that crap about
saving plan yeah downsizing is about
saving yourself we live like kings
we've got best houses best restaurants
Cheesecake Factory got three of them do
you undergo the permanent and
irreversible medical procedure commonly
known as downsizing and that your
products will be approximately two point
zero three six four percent of their
current massive value
[Music]
I know right
[Music]
[Music]
this is based on a book or something
this is crazy that was nuts that is not
at all what I was expecting when I heard
this title but the promise means it's
permanent like one day you just like but
you appreciate the world Maureen I think
it's funny cause like I have two cats
and then I imagine when you're a cat how
like everything just so much more
fascinating cuz everything's the first
trailer that showing you like and how
magical the committee to downsize had
become tiny I'm like that's true and
then I'm wondering like it's a halfway
through the movie where like
everything's gonna go I can imagine all
the worse things going wrong here dude
it's interent cuz you didn't expect that
yeah at all it's creative that's
creative it's nice to see Hollywood
doing a movie like this and Matt Damon
and Kristen we have good chemistry I
like Matt Damon random room that's a
ball his bass yeah a bald cat I don't
know he did it for Elysium he might have
done it for this this is true he was
like he does go all-in when he gets the
rolling and I mean like Alexander Payne
he hasn't made a bunch of film but it
seems like people do really invest in
his movies and he gets really good cast
dressing man
Jurassic Park 3c totally William animacy
as Ned Flanders
no rain it's a cool cast assembled I
love this I love the concept of it I
really it seems like it's going to take
full advantage of its exploration wall
is Jason Sudeikis is gonna bring all the
[Music]
what part of what I also enjoyed about
this was seeing how many like comedic
actors they got to be in this young cast
and I like when people stretch that way
because it looks like they'll definitely
be humor in this but it doesn't look
like a flower come it's nice to see
Christoph Waltz not playing a bad guy at
least from the trailer how it makes it
look what second demonstration wall to
the doors exactly he's not gonna be a
bad guy but he is gonna be the guy who's
like sleeping with everyone's wife if
you make this like a horse warm it's
perfect I really hope this movie's good
because I am SuperDuper intrigued by it
for sure it's a Christmas movie December
22nd it comes out well this looked kind
of kind of nice for Christmas time
because I know he's like his movies can
have a certain amount of melancholy to
them but this does look like that yeah
to be three days before Christmas
all these little people and watch three
get eaten by cats what I'm really hoping
for from this movie is it takes
advantage of the emotional exploration
this could have like really put you into
the world of being like part of the tiny
community of people and then seeing the
effect of enjoying it and then the
effect of missing out on being
regular-sized - I don't I see that I
feel like when they wrote the script for
this nobody had the treatment idea
somebody was watching big people little
worlds like what if you hear me
just hear me out what have we made them
smaller there's a medical procedure this
video Jeff bearskin Peterson Jeff
bearskin Peterson's it's like five foot
six guy he lives in another Minnesota
Minnesota really really talks a lot a
husky fellow Native American I would
love to see Jeff shrunk he would skin so
many tiny bears yeah yeah that is
actually the way Jeff functions I feel
like Jeff will be the most dominant tiny
guy that's what I would want to see a
dead guy
garlic Jeff just walking around I'm tiny
you know Jeff's observations through
that lens like have him just walk around
on the desk yeah I'll do in that giant
bottle absolutely absolutely
I can't disrespect those two boxes vodka
is weak you just don't care about your
knife and the part of somebody just
brought this to the party just cuz they
want everybody to make bad decisions
absolutely yeah you wanna make bad
decisions by yourself
haha I wanna have an absolute control
over your bad decisions I found to get
downsized I would want every part of me
to be downsized but my penis so my penis
would look exceptionally bigger than the
current age
so that it would be hard physically to
move their pants in traction forever
well
hear me out don't we told him that might
not be the best idea
try not to arouse him and so you won't
be able to remain conscious
we'll just be a penis alright guys well
we're gonna wrap this video up you can
subscribe to the real rejects click that
notification bell - John Humphrey on
Twitter and Instagram become a patreon
eject today most importantly check out
twisty sidekick podcast jay trusty the
clown sidekick podcast on the Internet a
link in description box Jay you gotta
send me a link to that and mr. Jay
Washington on Twitter and Instagram make
sure to follow this beautiful handsome
man over there thank you